I have a really important case study for you
today about how Republicans end up muddying
the waters and winning merely by distracting.
As you probably know, Donald Trump has been
impeached.
We have an impeached president, only the third
in the history of the United States.
We are now standing by for the Senate trial,
which will begin when SA a house speaker,
Nancy Pelosi sends the impeachment articles
that the house approved over to the Senate
and acquittal is all but a foregone conclusion
in the Republican controlled Senate.
I've talked about how it could go differently.
It's not likely to go differently.
This is all about Donald Trump, but Republicans
have been able to turn this around and make
it about Joe Biden during the last week, democratic
primary candidate and former VP Joe Biden
said to the Des Moines register last week,
he would not comply if the Senate subpoenas
him to the impeachment trial of Donald Trump
in the Senate.
Now, Joe Biden accurately told the newspaper
that sending a subpoena to Joe Biden would
be a way to take attention off of Trump and
that part he was right about.
But then he said that he wouldn't comply.
And of course, Joe Biden is right that subpoenaing
him to the impeachment trial would be an attempt
to distract from Donald Trump.
But immediately Republicans respond with,
how could this be?
Biden would ignore a subpoena, even though
Democrats won't stop talking about how Republicans
are ignoring subpoenas and they're terrible
because of it.
This Joe Biden not care about the constitution,
which is obvious concern trolling, but it
pushes the story to being about Biden instead
of being about Trump.
So then this leads to another round of Biden
talking about this.
Having to clarify Biden a few days later,
had to go back and say, well, hold on.
Of course I would obey a legal constitutional
subpoena tweeting about it.
In addition to talking about it, saying on
Twitter quote, I want to clarify something
I said yesterday in my 40 years in public
life, I have always complied with a lawful
order and in my eight years as VP, my office,
unlike Donald Trump and Mike Pence, cooperated
with legitimate congressional oversight requests.
But I am not just going to pretend that there
is any legal basis for Republican subpoenas
for my testimony in the impeachment trial.
That is the point I was making yesterday and
I reiterate this.
Impeachment is about Trump's conduct, not
mine.
The subpoenas should go to witnesses with
testimony to offer to Trump's shaking down
the Ukraine government, so now it gets more
muddled with commentary about the commentary.
Joe Biden said he wouldn't comply.
Then he said, of course he would comply, but
what I mean is it wouldn't make any sense
to subpoena me.
Republicans are great at this and Biden's
stepped in it.
What Biden should have said from day one is
this impeachment trial has nothing to do with
me.
Any attempt to pull me into it would be an
attempt to distract.
Of course, I believe in the constitution and
the rule of law and I will always do what
is legally required of me, but the idea that
I should be part of this Senate trial is a
political strategy make to meant to make impeachment
about me instead of about Donald Trump.
He didn't say that.
Instead, he sort of tried to be tough.
I won't go, but that's the wrong thing to
say.
He has to walk it back.
They are experts, experts in this.
They won't even fight the substance.
They distract, misdirect.
They get Democrats to argue with themselves.
We've got to be smarter.
We can't be falling for this stuff.
And Joe Biden did remember that.
Uh, tomorrow, January one big membership special
going out by email, an obscene discount, an
opportunity for you to put your name on the
record as a supporter of the David Pakman
show for 2020.
It's an election year.
This stuff matters.
Get on our newsletter by signing up@davidpakman.com
and then tomorrow you'll get an email with
an [inaudible]
instructions for how to take advantage of
this.
It's, it's so cheap.
It's disgustingly obscene.
The membership special we're running tomorrow,